who is the most famous person on the
planet for real like it may be her Tom
Cruz you think Tom Cruz that's the guy
who say look at how he comes into Stage
we seriously have to come onto stage one
day like this we ever do a live pay babe
I swear to God so this is what we're
doing oh my
God
we it looks like CGI did you see right
before it went he went a little oh my
God this guy's a legend
that dude he might be the most famous
person in the world wow his physicality
is wild he's the most famous that is one
million people look with the cowboy best
on what morons we are we're like oh
maybe Michael Jackson maybe Beyonce oh
sigh congratulations you're the most
famous person in the world